hey what's up I am here with Michael
mahardi I'm Jake and we're about to play
lawbreakers yeah uh I play a little bit
of it today and at a few preview events
of like uh packs and E3
it's pretty fast-paced shooter now it's
in uh Alpha for the weekend I think
until Sunday don't like quote me on that
completely
I will do all right let's jump in
have you played this yet I've not played
this I actually don't know a lot about
this other than the fact that it is
um
boss key games a shooter fast-paced
shooter yeah clipped wazinski Cliff
bazinski yeah there you go boss key
that's pretty much what everybody knows
about the game I guess
it's fun uh yeah it's
super like frenetic yeah kind of like
Quake almost
get rid of the PIP
oh
I don't know how to get rid of the PIP
um all right here we go
Chevy I'll start with the Vanguard class
is what I'm most familiar with
also is Tay on my Tas online
check the box
I don't want to uncheck the wrong box
all right so I'm pretty much being like
I don't know it's a Gatling gun class it
also has a jet pack cluster grenade
there we go which box
oh
not a lot of Textures in that gun are
there okay
oh there we go
all right
so what's the deal with this game what
it like a lot of people have been kind
of comparing it to OverWatch and stuff
like that
ah green pear and I know it's more like
it's way faster paced in OverWatch the
classes are more like
I said it's more of a quake kind of game
I mean in the sense that it's a shooter
I guess
strictly competitive shooter but like
this class is kind of a
weird blend of a few so it is class
based though yes
so I guess in that respect it's
overwatchish and then but do the class
have like different abilities and stuff
like that or is it just like weapons
nope they do uh different abilities so I
have like a jet I have oh [__]
cluster grenade enemy is charging the
battery
oh
oh that boost looks pretty cool though
like it's kind of like divas um jet from
OverWatch to make another OverWatch
comparison I compare everything to
OverWatch these days I'll probably play
that one watch is pretty good died not
just kidding I really like it that's a
joke
his my secondary attack it's like this
Force push but it damaged them a lot
just like pulverizes people
your team dude
all right so now it just like kind of
catch the flag when you have to defend
the battery for a few seconds
ding
I could change your old now I'm gonna
stick with this for now
your side has
said there's one I'm most familiar with
the battery
how many classes are there in the alpha
uh five I think four or five I'll switch
after this and check but five I think
can you like you customize these classes
even further or is it just kind of like
I think it's just class based I don't
know if it's up to you
at least in the alpha I don't think you
can I imagine there's got to be more
classes than right if this comes out and
you can't
change a lot
I don't know
it's a good question all right so yeah
there's
four right now
try this dude
let's go with this
never used him before so task wants a
war with
Sprint is that what that is I guess
he's also sounds pretty pissed off about
something
I wonder where he is
some some sort of grenade
sort of recharge by the time I
okay your side has taken the battery
is this rocket launcher yeah what is
that
let's find out
so you haven't been this class before
all right
did I hit him it looked like you hit him
not enough apparently
oh wow
that's uh that reminds me of like the
Watchmen happy face except for it's
happy but it's got blood on it you know
what I'm saying
okay so yeah it was just a lock on
Rocket I'll try him again
so is that fifth class just not
available or do you need to unlock it
uh it's not a little lock next to it so
the in the game modes those lock icons
were because there wasn't available in
the alpha so I'm assuming that's the
case with this
because I don't think I'm really
progressing I played a few matches I
didn't see any sort of like experience
okay so I could charge up all four
charges with missiles so that would be
ideal wouldn't it
your side is charging the battery oh
wow dang wow all right that guy didn't
want to go down no it's kind of slow
Time to Kill
let's try another class
rocket
all right let's try this out I don't
know what he does we'll find out
all right
okay rocket launcher class
all right dang
this looks like the the Spartan laser
Halo although it shoots nothing like
this part in laser button
all right nice
triple double kill triple oh [__] he's
not dead
defend this battery watch this doorway I
guess
oh you jerk
wait did I do that to myself no I don't
think so yeah I think he
kind of like that class
default is a rocket launcher it's hard
not to
enemy has stolen the battery
dropped the battery
your side sweet
your side is charging the battery
so this is just a multiplayer game
so okay there's not gonna be anything
wow that didn't kill him did that kill
him no
it's like a direct hit
it's got an assist though come over here
you jerk
and charge it
that looks like it's tough to land [__]
[Music]
what does that do I don't know it does
look like you threw it throwing knife
check that out next time I spawn now
it's like a little grenade but it like
sticks to spot all right so I got my ALT
enemy picked up oh you got your old now
too
all right now that I know what it does
I'll do it closer to people next time
okay so I just ran out but I still have
a rocket launcher
nice
is this a closed Alpha nope ah yeah
there are codes yes
it's like closed but not that hard to
get into shouldn't be and I'll clip with
like tweeting a ton of codes the other
day
oh it's just a proximity mine all right
let's try out her the blades try this
out
assassin
enemy has stolen the battery
you should get that shotgun
what is the battery what is that
supposed to be is that health no that's
like it's like Capture the Flag I'm not
really going for the objective now I'm
just trying this class so um yeah you
just get a battery and then you defend
it over on your own base
Mr mahardi
what's your name
hmm
so she's got a shotgun too
no
or yes
I'm gonna pull that shotgun out maybe
there we go
that's just an alternate weapon your
side is charging the battery
all right I feel like I've heard Justice
in the form of an ass kicking like six
times already yeah they have yet to add
more insults to the alpha I guess
enemy is charging the battery
people are saying it reminds him of Halo
yeah I mean it's like kind of a long
time to kill
so there's like these weird gravity
areas so this area is like gravity does
not work the same oh really okay so
that's what those things are for
all right that doesn't look safe
thank you
there was again yep oh [__] that's their
spawn
your side has taken the battery
kind of cool whatever that was yeah I
don't know what it was yours
yours oh
I don't think I use that all correctly
um oh cool okay I'm gonna go back to her
I like the uh the Vanguard
yeah I think you're doing pretty good
with the van card I think so and that
that movement's pretty sick yeah
oh my god there it is again yeah they
need to
give hire a few more voice actors or
something
or writers I guess would be
the thing you need for that
oh you idiot
actually I did that earlier kind of
see now this entire area is like
anti-graft someone right next to me
oh she's friends eating
that we love everybody
assist skill well she's dead oh you're
gonna die though no I'm not
low Health man you're gonna die
enemy has stolen the battery
what
she a surprise got me
your side has intercepted the battery
your side is charging the battery
wow
there we go
battery is fully charged Sweet let's
defend that [__]
so is that your melee move that can only
launches that thing uh it's got some
range on it but it's a close it's my
alternate fire okay I don't think I have
another weapon it's just this yeah the
wrist gallon gun it's kind of a funny
phrase
I thought that was bad victory
did pretty good for not uh going for the
objective at all I know way to be a team
player yeah it's probably my lack of
points reflected that though
do better next time I'll go for the
battery
feels good though yeah it looks like it
feels pretty good runs pretty smoothly
um the movement with that Gap wrist
Gatling gun dude the Vanguard looks
pretty cool yeah I've gotten like double
kills with the uh that like force push
thing because it does a lot of damage up
close good it's good against the
Assassins to push them away because it
does knockback but also just hurts them
yeah
kind of like this guy's a rifle though
I'm on the law now the law team
is there are the characters different at
all characters are different but the
weapons are the same
correct all right
the classes in general the same
all right we'll go through bombshell
uh clever spelling there
I like it now I get it
I think oh this is a different map
where is it
it is how many maps are there do you
know I don't know in the alpha I'm not
sure
oh man that's funny
I don't see you hit someone with that I
know it's tough like I don't you can't
it's a set distance every time it's a
really like time at well
they're like just know your reach
oh man
[Music]
can they shoot through those okay five
you found that out the hard way three
two one Bob Jones says you love that
rocket launcher yeah I do capture zones
to win Bob Jones Is Right
so not as mobile as I would like even
with that pounce drag them slams all
right
put a put a little oh that was sick did
you see how the grenade instead of
arcing it just went straight in the low
gravity
it's on the Bell now that's pretty cool
I like that nice little touch so do you
say this is someone in the chat is
saying like he doesn't get why people
are saying this is faster than OverWatch
does this seem faster than OverWatch
yeah yeah
like just the time to kill is faster uh
the maps are smaller you're it's more of
a centered map obviously OverWatch is
usually along paths
yeah you're right huh I'm also pretty
new the game so I'm not playing as fast
as I could be I think well this
character I guess might not be
yeah this character doesn't seem it's
just more of an arena shooter than
OverWatch It Ever Was or will be
nice oh wait I don't know if my mind or
my rocket and kill them both of them I
guess
oh he should do that one
oh so we're doing zones now all right
I'll go for the zones
we are playing the law Breakers Alpha on
PC if you enjoyed this make sure to like
And subscribe and do the usual kind of
things
uh yes and uh if you have any questions
be sure to let us know in the chat uh
we'll make sure to get to them all right
let's go for this Zone I guess is
someone in here what damn it oh that was
for sure I guess a proximity mine would
have been the the thing to do there
might switch back to a Vanguard pretty
soon
here we go
is that a gun just dramatic sound
effects
I feel like you've killed blunts Creek a
lot
track to my Rockets
I'm getting out of here do you have a
recharge on that thing
just don't bottom left oh okay I got my
berserk too so I can use that in a
second
go for C I guess
see what rails is doing lingling heal go
with this person
[Music]
dank
oh soon enough to defend him in the
aftermath you just get have to capture
them okay
really you have gained the lead
oh
yeah that mine helps a lot
I still I want to get that shift down
the pounce
Bob Jones wants to know what the
different classes are once uh he dies he
can stop shoot up
but there's a rocket launcher class I
guess which is what we're playing now
there's a heavy machine
a sword kind of close range glass and
what was the other one
got him dang
all right I will switch to the Vanguard
machine gun uh
the regular actually let's switch to
this one
there's a shotgun account like that yeah
the people made good choices it's kind
of cool oh this is the dude who says the
Justice needs an ass kicking or
something all right well we'll hear that
a lot get used to it
Blends creep again
get out of here
so this is kind of this feels like the
soldier 76 to keep making OverWatch
I like the reload animation with this
gun though
yeah that's sick just a ball what if you
missed like a Dyson Sphere it's like a
vacuum cleaner that turned into a gun
I think how dumb you'd feel though if
you just missed it
you have to chase down your ball
yeah
people are just making comparisons other
shoes
oh cool you get to hear that
what
that was sick
nice
[__]
that did not mean to go bad that's still
pretty cool though all right try out the
Vanguard again or no try the Assassin I
don't like the melee
I feel like
I thrive when I'm creating distance
between people not closing it
also this gun has like an Italian flag
on it
you're right it does
um
God of Hellfire wants to know if there's
any backstory or lore I'm guessing there
is I guess like do you know of what this
backstory in lore is yeah there's like
it's like cops and robbers I guess I
don't know okay
cops and robbers there you have it
oh it's a fast reload get out of here
nice
you're outnumbered yeah
all right I should get okay zones are
unlocked let's do it I'm gonna go back
to
I like this guy
[__]
away from winning
Sprint
Bang Bang
the classes feel good
yeah they all look pretty good look
pretty pretty different unique
three two one
I like the little Caution sign on the on
the gun nice little touch yeah
dang they keep getting like terms
[__] 13 huh that's an odd number I like
it though
wait what is this what is this
does it heal you I think he heals you oh
okay sweets that's good to know
yeah because like down below your health
like that thing was kind of turning
doing things I don't know three
on top of it though
this was that the end of no gravity pick
that bubble up top
just gets the way to keep you in the in
the area
yeah they need one
it's slightly better that time
yeah but you lost you should have just
not done the objective
what
I'm just kidding
all right let's play uh
let's play another one another couple
I'm gonna go back to Vanguard before I
like the Vanguard
I feel as if
you really have to control the map in
that mode
because like if they need two more zones
here
you can't give up any of them or if any
one more Zone obviously you have to
capture all three in that round which
puts you in a tight spot yeah what kind
of
what kind of game type was that was it
it was just capture points I was capture
points yeah but you get one point for
capturing you don't have to worry about
it afterwards it's not like you don't
okay okay meantime I see what you're
saying
this is not like a domination sort of
thing Chrono
yeah correct Tosca nine okay
everybody's being here
so now we're back to the lawbreakers
right the bad guys right
you read the law are you the breakers
she's shorter than I she looked oh maybe
I'm just tall
um God of Hellfire wants to know
um he wants to know what's the awareness
like
um I guess basically means like do you
feel like you can play without
communicating do you think communication
would help do you think in that last
game mode communication would have
helped but yeah I mean you can play
without it it doesn't seem nearly as
like teamwork oriented as uh OverWatch
it's uh you [__] with lifers you die
um
yeah it seems like I could just be doing
my own thing and as long as I'm focusing
on objective I'd be all right
pointed out have you seen that like all
the weapons seem to do nothing
what do you mean I don't know
most the characters I play can't seem to
kill anything that's what he means oh
damn horses
not good at the game no just kidding I
don't know the rocket launcher seems
pretty powerful
Dan I'm sorry I was joking um
I'll show you he works at twitch you
could shut this down you know talk bad
just pull the plug
okay let's try this
oh [__] oh oh kill them give me my
trustee oh that's still Skirmish [__]
someone just said chill it was just
Skirmish
she has surprised me have been gunning
for each other I think the battery kill
me
okay back to that other game mode I see
who's this can I Dan wants to know how
many kills you have right now we just
started this match though so nothing
right nothing
killed one in the beforehand I know or
two
enemy picked up the battery
get out of here dang wow
all right
charging I don't like the lack of
mobility of this class but it's pretty
good at killing people
back there oh man this is like I guess I
could use the pounds not really it
doesn't bring me that far
right it's weird that it's like a set
distance every time
I think it is I could be completely
wrong but
yeah
foreign
damn
I guess that pouncing into the middle of
the team is kind of risky
oh my God
this is what I like
oh Chinese Rockets get out of here
oh my God they're all here dang
is that an ALT or whatever
dang did he that was good
that might have been someone's like
anti-gravity I don't think so
all right let's uh
let's try to pick it up I'm not doing
too well
it's got someone yeah down there that's
she a surprise for his Vanguard
nice dang
oh surveys
nothing
got one person
Shia
dang brutal
just in the form of this one that's what
he said
just in the form of what Justice in the
form of ass whooping I thought he's
saying Justice needs an [__] family
what I thought he was on the Justice
side
um
thank you
they can destroy
there we go oh wow
that work what was that the cluster
grenade or like that was pretty sweet
the battery
come on man
I feel like he should have been dead by
then but maybe I just wasn't I feel like
should have been dead too
Tim the toolman Turner
no one's gotten a point yet oh they're
about to
charged
so they're gonna get this point in a
couple seconds unless you guys can stop
it
[Music]
dang all right well Chuck that up to it
should see if you can find one of those
Health boosts or whatever they are
oh yeah they're like Vita Chambers
almost yeah
so yeah for these people just coming in
this is the closed Alpha um you need a
code for unstein
uh I believe it's only on PC there are
lots of codes it seems like people in
the chat are like in YouTube and stuff
are just dropping code in there that's
good
it's fun I'd say take the time to play
it
okay sweet so we have the battery it's
good
there's a health move right there
defend that
wait that's taking a while to charge why
is it
um JW Smith wants to know if do you
think it would be
do you think do you think it would be
less fun without the gravity aspect do
you think it's needed
uh yeah it lends some like like a kind
of fluidity to it
um
otherwise
it also just adds verticality so you're
kind of like looking up too yeah or
you're worrying about like someone's
above you not just lateral movement
I think it's cool how like projectiles
and stuff like also change gravity yeah
like that grenade that adds a little bit
of a
little bit of uh
oh there's changes it up it's charging
not gonna go in there yet
I think I'm gonna avoid the OverWatch
questions
that was sick yeah yeah there we go
oh so it is that attack that creates
that I think this thing
um do we know when this game is coming
out
I do not know off the top of my head I'm
gonna guess it's a while since it's
still an alpha right
maybe this fall Sprint I don't know just
fall or spring I think don't take my
word for it we can look it up I guess
I believe I think it has a release date
but I'm not really sure when that is all
right so they only need two points we
should stop this
um
Jamie Shepherd wants to know if
do you think there are do you think they
need to add more weapons in classes it
would be nice to have more than five
because I don't know how I mean the game
it feels good mechanically it feels
really yeah but I don't know how long
that would
especially coming off OverWatch which
has like 21 not to keep bringing that up
battleborn is 25. OverWatch is 22 now 22
Yeah well battleborn is 27 now I think
health health to the left
oh I must load
let's just hang out here
just stopping us
maybe it runs out
oh
I got my ALT I like this Alt
what is going on in there
oh [__]
Bob Jones says November at the earliest
for this okay so it's not set then I
guess
um this is coming to console too yeah at
least probably
feels much very much like a mouse and
keyboard game though
well I guess
that's
I haven't played on controller actually
um JW Smith wants to know does he do
each of the characters feel different uh
from what I mean they look pretty
different watching playing like they
seem yeah they do
like play at different speeds different
different strats yeah hot strats dude
thought I killed deck I too but dang
that chain gun doesn't do much unless
you're really accurate
like she has surprise always is against
me uh someone wants to know if the works
with PC or with a controller I haven't
played the controller so I can't speak
to it but I'm assuming they but do their
due diligence to make sure it feels all
right
not a lot of Assassins this match
enemy picked up the battery
what does this grenade do Dan says He's
only seen like three kills from you
um
hmm
he is charging the battery
all right
I like his practice oh it's so slow
the battery is fully charged
remember how you open that door uh oh
that's not good
oh
dang
[Music]
oh man
doesn't seem like my thing
yeah usually I don't typically like
those kind of classes
just like I don't know sword play in a
first person shooter always feels kind
of weird
yeah I feel like it's just like trying
too hard to switch things up yeah
I guess to make sure that it's not all
just these medium range encounters
though
yeah
yeah there's no sniper right
not as of right now maybe not in the
yellow that's kind of weird
I don't know if I'd watch the name of
this game you'd have to be pretty pretty
good yeah
so far we've seen two different Maps
I think that's all there is in the alpha
out of six matches I played today it was
only these two
yeah people are getting tons of uh
codes oh yeah it's good yeah it's fun
check it out
try it play it
a shot
oh this is waiting for players duh
who
oh there's an assassin
assassinated me
adow all right
damn those Rockets actually travel
pretty fast there's not you don't need
to leave a ton
I would compare it to another character
we probably thinking of but
once flower bed right here
uh no this is not console this is PC
yeah this mouse just in case
in case you haven't thrown up yet today
die
all right sweet good thing oh this is
scrim all right good
so zones this is the one that I lost
last time two one keep doing that yeah
just do that the whole makes for a great
stream yeah I'll have a lot more health
for this character
five hundy
nice that proximity grenade dang she was
like darted through it or something
three two so I feel like some of those
Shields they can shoot through and
others they can't
yeah I have not figured out like the
color coding on that yet
[__] wait there's a zone right in the
middle
oh man I don't have a lot of Health left
Bob Jones know if you can play this with
the controller we don't know uh
you did a significant disadvantage I
think yeah
wow yeah it's pretty graphic
I don't think I'm doing damage to myself
when I do that
I don't know you always test it
see if you can do some rocket jumping
oh I can't but I think it hurt me yeah I
think it did hurt you
oh dragon
nice
all right so Zone a let's let's check
this out
oh shooting killer oh but you did yeah I
hit her
that was sick let's get this Zone let's
say let's get the zone
it's a war zone yeah it is
good to know all right let's hope they
got it about to use my ALT too if it
came in
step up on it
dang this reloading this is painfully
long well I mean it makes sense it's a
rocket launcher but still
three two one
step into the what Shadows maybe isn't
it I don't know that makes sense right
nice
throw that little dude
all right come on in buddy come on in
oh dang it not a lot of range on this
yeah
come in here nice
come in here there's nothing here just
me
fire
oh my God him but
good run it was a good run
I like the uh vanguards all a lot that
like
the lock on then you just do the ground
slam from there
yeah
yeah that would help if we got that
I don't think we're going to
I don't feel so good about it
what is it too
five
thirteen thirteen points to capture oh
really all right
oh I could have gotten a triple
just almost
oh I kill him I think so yeah
pull it away it's really an explode
though I know Direct Hit with a missile
to the face a raging dude missile
that sounded bad all right so I'm just
gonna hang out around here I like the
kills I'm getting with this rocket
launcher
I feel like I could lock this Zone down
if I play it right
uh No One's Gonna
sweet we got it
I would say the last one
let's do it
all right come on alt yeah
yeah I got it
all right I like this class A lot
still got my elk on might as well go
find someone
to electrocute their face
yeah we got the point too nice
okay let's find a health booth
[__] I don't know these maps at all
there's one oh it's in that hallway on
the other side of this area where that
person is
[Music]
oh [__] no
got her Cisco
okay I got my pounce but I'm not that oh
[__] I just left it damn it that's gonna
come on come on come on come on just
keep moving come on come on you got it
yeah yeah yeah
we're down two yeah they keep getting
like every time we set things too you go
oh man
I felt good that felt good I won't lie
all right
[__] get out of here dude
oh that was useless get inside
really low
um someone wants to know like what the
what the blast radius is like uh with
that rocket launcher does it still do a
lot of damage or is it you need direct
hits no you don't need direct hits I've
been getting a lot of fair amount of
kills without it
direct hits certainly help though wow
I feel like there's
finding those Health stations are pretty
tough to find
yeah I mean I know I know where one is
they're just on the other side of where
I wanted to be yeah
I guess they don't want to just pepper
the map with them
oh you got a huge Health bonus of this
too
in the lead
oh [__] no one's here all right oh this
one's unlocked God damn I'm not I don't
feel good about this threes only they
have
oh
someone in the chat says bloodborne is
great I agree with that
where did this person just go all right
let's go
oh you hit her
again
oh they got this one already sweet
okay can't you do that one
yeah I don't get that like what I mean
red maybe you can't see through because
this looks
damn they are wow they pulled away at
the last few rounds
okay so we need to take every single
zone from here on out to one yes sweet
sounds doable
especially based on our past performance
yeah I could see how this one would be a
good one too I've taken this one we
might lose them
taking this GD Zone gdz good to have
some communication here like all right
two here two here yeah [__] you get out
of it don't do that oh man all right
sweet so they'll they'll have one by the
time I respawn
maybe not no you know what I can do
oh we got two no that wasn't good enough
King of Kings wants to know how is the
game
how was the game yeah I like it it's fun
feels really good um the alpha doesn't
have a
breath of content right now two maps
four characters kind of two game modes
which is fun it gives me a taste of the
game I played it once before like packs
and uh
um
E3 I believe
so the the two game modes though are
those can you play those on both Maps
because so far it looks like we've only
played that
I think it seems like the game modes
have been attached to those yeah I
believe so
um I guess we'll probably find out a
couple more games yeah probably do one
more match
got time for one more
stick with the Vanguard for now
uh
Jamie Shepherd wants to know if you
think this is better than OverWatch and
Halo from what you've played so far I
think it's kind of tough to say at this
point yeah I don't want to I mean I
don't want to judge the entire game
based on an alpha as opposed to
OverWatch which is fully out uh I really
really like OverWatch
um this is fun well you gave it like a
what a OverWatch like a two out of ten
or something yeah yeah
it was all right
but uh
this feels like
it could be fun for a while I don't know
if there's enough
there's like a last thing to it yeah
but we'll see like I said it's it's an
alpha it feels good though like the I
feel like a game like this just has to
nail the mechanics and the feel and it
has so far it's impressed me
oh man I'm still used to that uh
um I don't think we know how many
characters are going to be introduced
upon release uh in this Alpha there are
four it looks like there's a fifth slot
it might be a long range sniper or
something
um I think they've announced it but I
just don't know maybe not
and we're we are playing this on PC uh
but I think it's coming to PC Xbox One
PlayStation 4.
all right
how long until you switch back to the
rocket launcher guy you think like five
minutes probably
the Assassin had a grappling hook I was
not utilizing
last game you did 14 and four because I
was using the rocket launcher a lot
stories
everyone keeps saying the reloads seem
too long in this game
um I mean for that assault rifle for the
enforcer class that didn't seem too long
the ball can you do it can you uh fire a
couple in whoops this one's gonna be
it's a chain gun but
although it doesn't feel like an
overpowered chain gun it feels like a
yeah it doesn't seem
s like an assault rifle
okay so the damage it's been doing
yeah that is a long reload I don't know
why that guy was not aiming at my feet
with a rocket launcher he clearly
doesn't know how to use the class
as opposed to oh I guess PS4 and Xbox
One versions are not confirmed yet oh
damn
prepare for combat oh did I just use
some of that no I love how the icon's
just a jet bottom left one
take the battery to your base and charge
it up to win
oh so this is the other game mode at
this
bubble though right or is this the level
you always play this game mode no this
is this is the one that I always play
this one okay never mind
your side dropped the battery
enemy intercepted the battery
oh [__]
enemy is charging the battery
oh I went right into that one
[Music]
thank you
foreign
electronic dessert thing
oh I love that Force push all right
there we go
yeah these classes all feel really good
I love these these two I haven't really
messed but I haven't mastered any of
them but I haven't felt the assessed got
the Assassin down yet
whoa I don't have my Force push thing
ready where's the recharge on that I'm
not seeing it
all right I'm doing it
oh wow
he wants you dead wait I don't think I
killed her I think I
I'm really low
oh all right
um do you want to call it there then
take that as a sign we should end it
um oh no do you wanna do one more I'll
do one more yeah let's do one more let's
uh end on a complete game yeah
so yeah here's the three game modes
well the one game mode I don't know what
the other two are
did I type this yeah I'm trying to
figure out what this chat is
we'll say it
GG Cliffy B is an [__]
all right so
same exact map and nope never mind yeah
same map
oh there are game modes are on both Maps
I believe okay
wow all right
what gun is that hold on a second
so maybe I do I just have to
someone just hit me with a sniper rifle
really yeah
interesting yeah maybe you do have to
unlock that class
Health yep
there there it is it's making mental
note of this area
JW Smith wants to know the frame rate is
is it consistently 60 uh it feels like
it yeah it seems like it seems pretty
smooth
um has I haven't seen any like
chugging at all
oh get out of here dude
just as in the form of an app ask for
things just doubled it
and then right after the other
side
thank you gonna get health now
dang it's close
um the blue aura thing I think if it's
what you're talking about is uh it it
separates like the gravity right
uh something like that yeah I'm still
having a difficult time figuring that
out completely yeah because like some of
them we can shoot through others we
can't oh wow alrighty then
all right this house is not my thing
is this still
playing yet dang it's about to end
Thomas Mateo wants to know if the game
feels too slow you know it's pretty fast
all right here we go
prepare for combat we are the
lawbreakers four three two or just the
breakers
capture zones to win
someone killed him
oh sweet I hit her a lot
yeah that reloaded super quick yeah
tosses it right in and that's it
um
do you know what graphics card we're
using in this uh this one wants to know
980 980 probably 980. Titan yeah
actually I don't know it's Tay's
computer I'd have to ask him they would
know maybe he'll say something in the
chat
all right wow
yeah switch switch to this guy try to
win this one
position
three two one
[Music]
yeah so the Assassin kind of feels like
a tracer like a skirmisher he's trying
to disrupt them from getting to the
points maybe yeah
um
someone wants to know
what do you think they need to add to
this game so we've kind of already
talked about adding more characters
would probably be good obviously Maps
um but is there anything else maybe that
if you like this game is missing
um I mean yeah like like you said like
classes more classes maybe yeah there we
go oh we got B sweet tied it up
died but it was worth it
I mean it's not gonna be like a there's
not gonna be a campaign but yeah
I don't think every game needs campaign
at all Rainbow Six Siege doesn't
OverWatch doesn't Titanfall 2 does now
or it's gonna
Titanfall one didn't though I'm excited
for that campaign I didn't have a single
player campaign sorry I had like that
multiplayer campaign thing that doesn't
count though yeah
three two one
dang all right
um Tom T-Bone wants to know if the game
is good has a good map layout uh from
playing the alpha does it encourage
Mobility
uh yes very much so especially with the
gravity or lack of gravity in certain
areas kind of like make sure there's
like it's not just lateral movement not
just like a
regular firefights are actually kind of
like between the floating and the actual
verticality and different elevations it
kind of makes you
look up along a y-axis as well
nice
oh three
she had a double kill too
does the setting feel memorable
interesting at all no all right I don't
know what's going on with it really
dang
um so I guess to answer your question JW
Smith no it doesn't it's not that oh
[__]
nice
oh wow
probably should have seen a little thing
she took a lot of damage
so theoretically they could win next
round if they take all the zones again
all right now next round next two rounds
in the next two
oh the Rockets don't have like infinite
range until they die yeah I noticed that
earlier
yeah let's just lock down a so we can
have one no there's way too many people
here this is not gonna do anything
all right whatever I just lost some
points for stepping out of there but
whatever
it's not what we're here for
dang see what this looks like they're
taking the middle one and then kind of
going out from there see or just having
one person hang back at sea
you jerk yeah you guys didn't even get
like you couldn't even get there in time
well that's why we want to die less so
then we have to worry about the respawn
screwing us over
uh is there anything you want the
developers to change about it any like
balancing that seems off
um
not off the top of my head no
the rocket launcher feels a little bit
if you're using it right kind of
overpowered I mean I know I'm not
demonstrating that right now but
damn they got be already
is anybody getting a no okay
yeah health
y
what damn
oh if they take that we lose
I think we lost I think you're gonna
lose
yeah we know
this looks like Halo right here actually
that's a sick ferris wheel
that does look like a Facebook that
probably is one
this thing what is this
that Skybox pretty cool
all right
well there's the game
defeat
[Music]
I don't know so I guess to
wrap up
um
overall thoughts on I know we've kind of
said it a few times already but I think
people would like to know
what's your thought of it overall it
feels good like it's very frenetic kind
of kinetic game there's a lot of uh
up and down movement which I like I like
which uh good Shooters I think can
incorporate that
um I also think that the classes feel
distinct and good
um
they feel like it feels like movement
it's like the thing they're focusing on
yeah which is which is cool because like
I think more and more Shooters are doing
that Titanfall nailed it when it first
came out like 2014-13
um
yeah I mean it definitely piqued my
interest from just playing like what
seven matches today so yeah we'll keep
playing definitely recommend giving a
shot yeah for sure
all right well that was our stream of
lawbreakers make sure to like subscribe
and uh
let us know what you think about the
game uh and for more on law Breakers
stay tuned to gamespot.com
foreign